good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight
after three tries more than three
decades of
attempting it joe biden last night
finally got his party's nomination
a year ago virtually no one would have
predicted this moment for most of the
long primary season
biden floundered near the bottom of a
crowded field he got so few votes in new
hampshire he didn't even bother with a
concession speech
he fled the state on a late night
charter flight and tried to pretend it
never happened
in the end biden won anyway the last kid
picked for kickball somehow wound up
captain of the team
so no matter what you think of him that
is an undeniable
achievement and yet still even now very
few people take joe biden seriously
why is that well if you've seen biden
talk you know why
he is fading that's not a partisan point
it's not intended to be cruel
it's true 77 year olds generally are not
meant to lead large countries
77 is not the prime of life it is old
age
vigor declines over the course of a
lifetime particularly in men
joe biden has grown weak that's why we
don't take him seriously
but as it turns out there's another way
to look at joe biden's decline it's a
perspective that hasn't occurred to most
republicans
but clearly it's at the center of the
democrats election strategy
yes joe biden is slowing down for 50
years he couldn't stop talking
now he has trouble starting sentences he
forgets words he misnamed states
occasionally he mistakes his sister for
his wife
every time he gets confused biden grins
in that charming way old people do when
they know they're losing it
so yes joe biden has gotten a little
daffy but for that very reason
he's not going to hurt you there is
nothing threatening
about him he's not aggressive or overly
ambitious
in a time of chaos and shouting it might
be comforting to be led by a man who
talks about record players and wears
slippers with the socks attached that's
the actual message
the subtext of the biden campaign no one
in the democratic party will say it out
loud no one ever will
but biden's handlers understand that his
punchiness
could be his biggest asset because biden
is so obviously ineffective
he's harmless because he is passive you
assume he is well-meaning
you wouldn't put joe biden in charge of
your dinner reservations but on the
other hand he's probably not going to
send you to an internment camp
in that way biden is the mirror image of
say elizabeth warren
warren's eyes gleam with the menacing
promise of germanic efficiency
biden's eyes are like windows onto an
empty sky
there's nothing there just a placid void
democrats see an advantage in this a
party that no longer represents the
mainstream
needs a leader who won't scare voters
joe biden's job is to soothe your fears
about what the left will do if they ever
take power
stacey abrams or beta aurora could never
do that their plans for you
are too obvious joe biden has no plans
the most radical mass political movement
in american history has found a front
man
who seems like he should be feeding
pigeons democrats are happy about that
if you didn't see biden speak last night
you may not fully appreciate this
dynamic
some republicans in washington will tell
you that biden's acceptance speech was
scary
it's their job to say things like that
but in this case that's not true
watch this clip and ask yourself what
you disagree with
but while i'll be a democratic candidate
i will be an american president
i'll work hard for those who didn't
support me as hard for them as i did for
those who
did vote for me that's the job of a
president
to represent all of us not just our base
or our party
this is not a partisan moment this must
be an american moment
it's the moment the calls for hope and
light and love
hope for our future light to see our way
forward
and love for one another america isn't
just a collection of
clashing interests of red states or blue
states
we're so much bigger than that an
american moment an american president
an american leader who represents
everyone regardless of party
a country that's more than just a
collection of clashing interests
a future with hope and love for our
fellow americans
that's what joe biden promised last
night is there anyone who doesn't want
that
well the leaders of joe biden's party
for one thing what you just heard does
not represent the dnc's vision for
america it's not even close
read their platform watch their speeches
we just spend all week doing it
democratic leaders are not calling for
unity they're demanding division
they staged an entire convention that
amounted to an extended tribute to the
zero-sum
viciousness of identity politics this
group gets this
that group deserves that give it to us
now a nation of 350 million people
splintered into countless warring tribes
united by nothing
apart from a common loathing of their
own country it was an
orgy of anti-american grievance
mongering
and from start to finish it was
relentlessly savagely partisan
even by the standards of a partisan
political convention
watch the reverend freddie haynes
explains that jesus hates republicans
too
you had the nerve to build a wall while
at the same time you have in
the harbor there in new york the statue
of liberty
saying give me your tired your huddled
masses yearning to breathe free
jesus will say america if you don't get
your act together
you can you may well go to hell
america is headed to hell says the
reverend freddie haynes
damned for eternity flames smoke
pitchforks
gnashing of teeth the whole thing that's
not speculation
it is a straight red letter prediction
from jesus himself
and also by the way from the reverend
jeremiah wright of chicago
jeremiah wright was the reverend freddie
haynes's spiritual mentor he and barack
obama have that in common
jeremiah wright didn't actually speak at
this week's dnc but he was certainly
there in spirit
kamala harris channeled jeremiah wright
in her prime time speech
watch harris diagnose america with a
fatal case of racism
there is no vaccine for racism
we've got to do the work
for george floyd for brianna
taylor for the lives of too many others
to name
we've got to do the work to fulfill
that promise of equal justice
under law because here's the thing
none of us are free until all of us
are free there's no vaccine
explains dr harris looks like the
patient won't make it sorry
america is dying from the virus of
racism and there's nothing we can do
we've reached the limits of modern
medicine
we're going to let this country go and
start over kamala harris was hardly the
only one to say that
speaker after speaker this week hit the
same theme america is beyond redemption
tear it down and build a new country
with us in charge there's just no
vaccine for america's sin
it's terminal it's unlikely that any
major political party has
ever had speakers say anything like this
from the podium
attacking the country you're trying to
lead is a radical move and typically
it's not a good way to win a majority
but this message wasn't aimed at the
majority in fact they would rather you
didn't hear it
that's why they trotted out joe biden
the job of a president is to represent
all of us biden reassured the country
last night not just our base
everyone's for that and yet virtually
every word at the convention other than
biden's speech was aimed directly at the
left's base the coalition of the
miserable
that is the engine of the democratic
party needless to say the base loved it
here's the single
dumbest talking head on the single
dumbest cable news channel clapping her
hands
in infantile glee because democrats
managed to exclude an entire racial
group
from this week's proceedings and she's
grateful for that she just couldn't bear
to look at them anymore
it was all about representation my
little melanated
cynical heart my immigrant melanated
woman heart felt so full last night
actually today is today with david and
john is the first time i see a white man
like in
eight hours this you know other than
than joe biden last night and that's
okay
they've had 240 years of representation
they're going to be okay
what kind of person would say something
like that or even think it
if you ever catch yourself feeling
thrilled that you don't have to see
certain racial groups if you find people
who look different from you
that horrifying that repulsive then you
can be certain that you are indeed a
racist a nasty one too
and that's exactly the sort of person
the democratic national convention was
aimed at
meanwhile outside the convention the
base stayed busy
thousands of biden voters worked to help
the democratic ticket
in the ways they know best by hurting
people and destroying things
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
none of that was hidden anyone who lives
in an american city or can navigate a
computer knew exactly what was going on
but if you got your news exclusively
from the democratic message machine you
would have no idea you'd have no clue
that your country
was being completely reshaped by
violence in the streets there was no
mention of that at all from democratic
leaders at the convention this week
antifa wasn't allowed to send delegates
various speakers made blm
sound like a branch of the united way
the media did not contradict this
message they simply refused to cover the
violence outside
it was like it all never happened it's
possible that joe biden never found out
about it
biden doesn't get outside much he knows
only what they tell him
judging from his speech last night biden
has come to believe that he is mahatma
gandhi
leading a movement to restore love to
the human heart
we can choose a path of becoming angrier
less hopeful
more divided a path of shadow and
suspicion
or or we can choose a different path and
together
take this chance to heal to reform to
unite
a path of hope and light a path of hope
and light
it sounds like a beatles lyric from
their acid face but actually it's a
beautiful sentiment if we're being
honest who doesn't want hope and light
we all do all decent people want that
and that's why it's a winning message in
a national election
unfortunately it's also a deeply
dishonest message
unity is not what the democrats are
promising unity is not what they plan to
deliver
the media understand that very well
they're committed democrats themselves
hope and light please these people
cheered when they thought roger stone
was going to die in prison for some
made-up crime
they cried when he was spared these are
hardened
partisans not just the ones whose
brothers are sitting governors
they know perfectly well that what joe
biden said on stage last night
was absurd but they also know that many
americans will believe it
so they loved the speech it may have
been the best speech
that joe biden ever delivered i think
this may be the best speech joe biden
has ever delivered
this was one of the strongest speeches
of joe biden's
career it was probably the best speech i
ever heard
joe biden give whoever wrote that speech
needs to get a cookie and a hug and a
flag
and a puppy it is that thing was crafted
so well
he came ready chris he absolutely did he
spoke passionately
and from the heart it is a tale of two
visions
of what this country is about one is
about anger
joe biden gave you something very
different tonight he said and i quote
i will draw on the best of us he i am
just
like if i could jump out of the chair i
mean this is the best night for joe
biden
ever the best night for joe biden
ever jennifer granholm might be right
about that
unfortunately in the short term lies
often work